[Music]
what once was old is new again once more
an official Lego set for an upcoming
Marvel flick in this case the
long-awaited Avengers and game may have
revealed a major spoiler namely the
return of the sheet re the invading
alien race from the first Avengers movie
over the years plot points such as the
destruction of Tony Stark's home in Iron
Man 3 the presence of the Hulkbuster
armor in Avengers age of Ultron Scott
Lang going big during the airport brawl
in Captain America's Civil War and more
have been spoiled for fans by LEGO sets
released in advance of the respective
films debuts 1 leaked official set for
endgame appears to be carrying on this
tradition but the inclusion of minifigs
which really can't be anything other
than Chitauri warriors who laid waste to
New York and the climactic battle in the
first Avengers film the attack was shown
in that film's post-credits sequence to
have been orchestrated by Thanos but it
was headed up by Loki who was under the
malicious influence of the Infinity
stone housed in his scepter bolstering
the speculation our set photos from
endgame then appeared late last year
showing our heroes revisiting the Battle
of New York presumably as part of their
master plan to reverse the extinction of
half of all life in the universe brought
about by Thanos and his finger snap at
the end of infinity war the presence of
shatori warriors in the Lego set
suggests that the Avengers won't simply
be picking through the rubble for clues
but may actually have to relive the
battle in one form or another
possibly even purposefully altering its
outcome in order to create conditions
favorable to bringing about the 1 in 14
million plus possibilities that results
in the heroes eventual victory over
Thanos as outlined by Doctor Strange the
lego set also features a new Hulk Buster
like suit for war machine so it's likely
that this do-over won't just be a tired
rehash so the likelihood that our heroes
will have to engage in a bit of light
time travel in order to reverse the
Knossos victory is all but certain at
this point but it might not be actual
time travel remember Tony Stark's
technology from Captain America Civil
War which allowed users to
holographically reconstruct incidents
from their past using their memories if
that's what we're seeing the return to
the Battle of New York would constitute
some kind of fact-finding mission
perhaps a search for some weakness of
that was overlooked the first time
around and all the carnage but we've
gotten a few significant clues in the
intervening months that this is likely
not the case first there's the post
credit scene of ant-man in the wasp in
which Scott wound up trapped in the
quantum realm when those tasked with
pulling him back out were all dusted
before they could do so before entering
the quantum realm
Scott was sternly warned and don't get
sucked into a time vortex we won't be
able to save you the first teaser
trailer for endgame revealed that Scott
was indeed able to extract himself
somehow will the venerable amp man's
experience with a quantum realm come
into play in the Avengers plan well
Scott says he has want to do take
exactly the action he was warned not to
employing some timey wimey trickery to
help the team revisit the Battle of New
York it certainly seems possible on the
other hand we also know that brie
Larson's Carol Danvers aka Captain
Marvel set to appear in her own 90 set
feature next month will play a major
role in the events of endgame as teased
by the infinity war post credit sequence
in which samuel l.jackson znik fury puts
out a distress call to the good captain
before he too crumbles to dust in a
recent interview with total film jackson
made a comment about Dan vs. powerset
that could be seen as particularly
revealing Jackson said Captain Marvel
can time travel so maybe she can get
ahead or behind or whatever and figure
out what all that is the fact that I
have the pager used to put out the
distress call twenty years later it gets
addressed in an interesting sort of way
now this could be seen as a sort of
off-the-cuff comment as Captain Marvel's
time travel abilities have never been
brought up prior but it can also be
assumed that Jackson knows plenty about
the events of endgame that we don't and
he just might have let a major plot
point slip however it happens the good
folks at Lego have clued us in to the
fact that Earth's Mightiest Heroes will
indeed have to relive their greatest
victory one way or another we'll see
what it all means when Avengers endgame
hits theaters on April 26 2019 check out
one of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos about your
favorite MCU films are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
you